ladies you're making too much noise are
you doing a [ __ ] gesture right now Oh
from behind you guys are no Stephanie
but stephanie is just [ __ ] she just
pink is really out with this joke right
Wow I wish you guys seen that
hey guys Christians and Jews and any
religion that you are if you're not
religious welcome to the real rejects
I'm Ryan Wright Danielle and I are gonna
check out today the official trailer
number one for the boss I know what it's
like to be a boss actually on my own
boss Danielle it's so nice I don't need
to rely on anyone for my income except
for the owners of YouTube that's really
nice copyright strike two morons channel
shut down
I love Melissa McCall Kristen Bell's in
this yes she's one of my Hollywood
crushes if I had a Hollywood crush she
would be like number four I don't like
her oh well you made things in our
friendship awkward permanently thank you
sexual content and language and brief
druggie come on drugs are what makes
this country run
I wanted to come down on a golden
Phoenix and I sure as [ __ ] didn't want a
single mom I deserve the pay raise you
have a child yeah but that's weird of
course yes I usually get kind of an
asexual vibe I'll have a picture with
genitals myself returning bankrupt all
your accounts have been frozen hmm if
she doesn't have anywhere to go she
should stay here look at that baby this
sofa careful it's a bit temperamental
take Rachel to her dandelions meeting
our cube came in with one hundred and
eighty nine thousand dollars holy [ __ ] I
jumped two parolees attending our
meeting minutes of a box of chocolate
clusters up that tight passengers this
is my way back we are gonna start a
brownie Empire and teach these girls
real business skills they want some good
recruits get in there go for the
aggressive girls I feel kind of sweaty
and scared it's just the coffee kicking
him oh you know what oh I may have
switched them I put a little splash of
bourbon at night
Michelle Darnell and this is my partner
and I don't mean partner like
girl-on-girl stuff
let's go a little closer something
you're gonna dabble with in college but
not stick with I know don't tell bless
your Hannah I think it's gonna fit you
like a glove okay crystal what do we say
if somebody doesn't want to buy buy my
brownies or I'll kill you that sweater
just says I give up you know they're
insecure right before my date don't if
you could hear these bad basset hounds
maybe st. Claire what is the bug mess
now please don't set me up in your genes
let me see this Claire it's like
Geppetto if there's any actress out
there that can be a mean [ __ ]
it's Melissa McCarthy it's like even
movies that are like terrible they're
still good because she is so funny like
like like Tammy yes you would say Tammy
was funny so would I Warner Brothers no
thanks for sending me the blu-ray I'm
thinking of a one um identity identity
but then jason bateman so so I hate
identity thief yeah but they're both so
fun you can't hate it I know that is one
of the worst movies I've ever seen yeah
well I know how you are don't move away
from me anybody here Melissa McCarthy
does have this incredible ability to
make mean characters likeable like she
can be mean and nasty but be likable I
like how she kind of doesn't seem like
low-class mean like she's like this
upper-class kind of ignorant sort of
naive doesn't realize what she's really
saying I like how her husband is back in
the
yes so great he I hope he just he makes
an appearance in like everyone various
it was a great actor he is a pretty
funny dude actually looks like melissa
mccarthy lost some weight no she did it
i know she's wearing a turtleneck the
whole show
yeah i would eat in that's 14 should
surgery oh I thought she did why would
you assume she had surgery why don't you
bring it girl like the entire movie I
know but that simply give me a part of
her character like the classiness know
like when people get pregnant and they
would do a whole pregnancy thing or like
when people you know they're covering up
she probably had girdle removal girdle
removal you know this stuff yeah yeah
yeah you got a lot of that coming in
Boise ouch bloating racing I'm so fat
there look like I can pop that's mean
and I think she pulls off the wig to
come on she looks like this carrot like
I feel like she's really doing a
character in this one if you guys are
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects become a rejected a
yeah you all want to be labeled that
don't you Danielle has nothing on the
internet really she has an Instagram on
her on Instagram it's nothing but
half-naked photos for you guys actually
yeah it's nothing but that you guys but
will not be disappointed if you follow
her on Instagram disappointed if you are
going for that trust me you're going to
be very happy